welcome to film courage this is episode
165 I'm Karen warden and I'm David
Brandon you can find our archives on
iTunes film courage and now on YouTube
for those of you who like to watch these
conversations happen yeah today's guest
is filmmaker Pablo Pappano from the film
clicking for love clicking for love is a
funny and telling feature-length doc
about the world of online dating Pablo
does a wonderful job in keeping
interviews in the doc clicking for love
fun shocking and in some instances a
little scary yeah Pablo what he did is
he went to craigslist and any posted and
that he was seeking people who are
willing to share their experiences with
online dating tagging and essentially as
soon as he did that his inbox was just
flooded with messages um you know and
and he got a ton of responses ranging
you know stories ranging from the good
you know this is way he puts it the good
the bad and the downright disturbing
yeah and also sort of came pouring in on
he realized that there was much more to
online dating then he initially expected
and thus had the makings of an awesome
documentaries yeah and people were very
candid with him and and surprisingly so
there was some really juicy information
in there if Pablo mentions that you know
internet dating has been around for what
13 years and he still isn't sure whether
it's you know something that really
works for people is happily ever after a
realistic goal for online daters so you
can find out more by visiting clicking
for love to purchase an online version
of the film which we highly recommend
and if you're not an online dater um
it's a great gift for someone who is mhm
yeah with that Pablo welcome to the show
no thanks guys i'm a big fan you show
because you know and i'm so excited to
be on here so thanks for having me and
talking about my movie oh you got it man
thank you thank you for emailing us for
your article as well oh great yeah i
hope it helps people and because I've
learned a lot you know this process is
in
through listening to other podcasts and
then just my own experiences so yeah
it's been an interesting experience and
it kind of like what you said how the
film is people who have done it they
will relate to it and people who are
thinking about it they'll either maybe
help them make a better decision about
it so then other people who were at you
know in relationships they can kind of
get an idea of what internet dating is
so it's kind of what out of film and it
works for a lot of people and it just
seems like a lot of people are doing it
they're not admitting it to so you know
we're going to go you know we're gonna
go pretty in depth here this
contribution as we go back and forth
once again to see Pablo's work go to
clicking for left clicking for love calm
and you can find them on twitter at
cancer man tickety cancer man 28 and
we're going to we're going to find out
about sort of you know why you had that
handled as well and just just just the
Chairman so well first off Pablo
congrats to you on making this
entertaining and interesting doc about
online dating you know you really found
some just fascinating interview subjects
and just to touch on a few of the people
that are in the film my favorite was
Audrey um and you say that she's
40-something actress who fell in love
with a mysterious South African boat
captain sounds very intriguing and you
can find out more about what happens in
the film if you watch it and then
there's Marty the likable middle-aged
father of three who's also swinger with
with a black book of thousands of names
but he also wants to find you know it
seems like more than just that physical
connection he's looking for the
emotional connection as well and then
there's Colleen she's a single chef in
the catering business who's sort of
looking for you know maybe friends with
benefits like she doesn't want the
boyfriend but then she doesn't want the
one-night stand and she wants people to
understand her work schedule and then
you've got Andy who's the professional
and he's he's looked for women different
places and he's had some interesting
offers I thought the one about what
going on the first date and
the father offered him you know a part
in the family business some money to
have children so you come up with some
just great interview subjects let's
rewind a little bit before we go into
actual doc did filmmaking begin for you
once you entered film school or was it
sort of always churning in your mind
before you went to film school I think
is a young kid when I was probably
around twelve and my parents are alive
avid moviegoers so I just always loved
movies and then I always wanted to make
movies and I would try with my friends
but it's always hard to you always want
to make something beyond what you're
capable of you know was you know I
didn't want to make this typical click a
kids movie I wanted to make like a
violent you know movie or a sci-fi movie
and you know I was always frustrated by
the limitations we know when you said
the neighborhood kids and then they lose
interest and so I always tried to make
movies but film schools probably where I
actually start to complete my projects
and you know kind of realized a dream
and you kind of get to understand well
how does this process actually work but
yeah I was always when I was since I was
a kid I never had a back-up plan I was
like I'm going to film school i'm in a
big movies and that was it so Wow I mean
I mean it's really something to be on
that path Pablo we're here you are it's
like you know what you want to do you're
in film school and you're and you're
sort of honor your on that path of like
okay this is what I'm going to do with
my life and then you had some
life-altering news call me waking can
you tell us about that what would happen
yeah I was 19 and I was going to
starting my second year film school and
at the time I was I mean it still kind
of heavy now but at the time was a lot
heavier and I just thought I was out of
shape but what it was I thought that I
had leukemia and I was constantly short
of breath and just had difficulty
sleeping difficulty keeping food down
just so many little problems always felt
feverish and finally I came home visited
my parents and I was jaundice and they
said you know you don't look good so
they took me to the emergency room then
they were able to figure out that I had
leukemia because my white blood cell
count was really elevated and leukemia
is cancer the blood so my white blood
cells have mutated reading on my red
blood cells which carry the oxygen so
that's why I have a short of breath
so right away for 30 days as the
hospital started treatment for the
leukemia and then after that I relapse
and then I had to have a stem cell
transplant so it kind of took me off out
of school for a couple for anything
about two years and then I came back in
you know completed schooling after that
but I mean it definitely really changed
my perspective on life and I think made
me probably a better filmmaker to the
long run well I'm sure going through
such traumatic process like that matured
you how did you look at other people
your own age who hadn't sort of been
dealt with any life blows how did you
see them from afar having gone through
this yeah that was interesting
especially going back to college because
I was older than a lot of the people who
were typically sophomores and yeah you
totally saw I mean it was totally
different and I wasn't living on campus
so I wasn't you know as a part of a lot
of that stuff but yeah you totally kind
of said how people were a lot more
immature because you think you're
invincible when you're 18 or 19 you
think nothing's going to happen to you
you can drink as much as you want you
could do whatever you want and you'll be
fine and you just kind of you do
appreciate you know life more and I
think maybe you do take better chances
with things and like I was more of an
introverted person I think I became a
little bit more outgoing I wasn't as
passive like I would approach people you
know if there's a filmmaking opportunity
I would say you know I make movies you
know what I'd like to work with you
whereas before I was just more timid and
so it changed I think my outlook and I
think it changed just how I had looked
at other people around me too because I
think and not that they were doing
anything wrong but it's just like I had
a different viewpoint on it than they
did so and I and I had some limitations
and I still do terms of doing like you
know the grunt work that goes along with
filmmaking after cancer because it's
like you do have lingering effects after
you have chemotherapy and radiation a
lot stuff so I mean did that time away
from film school to that did that make
you want to be a filmmaker more like
during that time and what were you doing
what were you doing besides you know the
treatment what else were you doing
during that time I think
first I kind of thought well this isn't
this isn't that meaningful like maybe I
should become a doctor or do something
different you know the thinking that you
know filmmaking is kind of frivolous and
you know maybe I should become a nurse
and help people and because I saw how I
mean nurses some of them are like Saints
I mean what they have to do for us is
especially the really good ones and
doctors too so I kind of got on that
path a little bit but then I you know so
you know it really loved movies it's
kind of my first passion and at the time
I mean I had that when when I came out
of my stem cell transplant I it wasn't
clear earth why I was gonna have all my
mental faculties back so it took a while
for that to come back and then I had a
neuropathy so it's like no you're
basically treating your body bellies
toxins to get rid of all the cancerous
cells and everything so you have these
side effects so it takes a while until
you caught kind of feel like you're at
your your norm again so basically I just
kind of Rico recuperating then I took
some classes at a junior college because
that it wasn't sure if I could handle
that kind of course load again then they
kind of gave me the confidence to say
yeah I can go back to the University and
finish so that's basically what I did
nothing I did actually read some scripts
to at the time well you mentioned that
maybe before you got sick that you ever
made you a little more passive and you
didn't take as many chances and and
we're introverted and then you begin
meeting women online before was really
the norm i mean i think i remember back
in the 90s like there was the Pennysaver
and they would have these person they
didn't really have you know all that
they have today can you tell us about
what you were doing back then to meet
women online well back then for me I
mean this is kind of before the match
and all that stuff happened and he was
starting but I would go on AOL on they
had chat rooms and they had like an LA
chat room like a romance I mean they
have like film chat room you know just
different ways for people to come and
talk and you know you just see there be
maybe these age sex location checks for
people would say 18 3 100 mail and then
or you know vice versa for a woman so
you know we're people in relation to
where you were and then maybe you'd send
him a message
say hey how are you doing and then you
know try to have a conversation then
usually the exchange a picture or you
sometimes wouldn't see a picture then
that was kind of a red flag and and then
you know eventually you try to get their
phone number and then you try to call
them and go out with them and you know
see what happens it's almost you know
kind of like meeting somebody in a bar
and since you know you kind of just the
same kind of questions you know what do
you do what do you do for fun and then
but you know you obviously don't see him
so that's kind of what i would do is uh
do that but I mean it's kind of like
what Barney does now a craigslist in the
movie hound you send out other messages
and you know so many people respond and
then you know hopefully you like that
person and it's also adding for film
festivals how it works too is you send
out tons of them you know admission 10
tons of checks and copies your film and
you hope that some Mia wanted it's a
numbers game right I was great too
because I think it showed him like doing
this template that he would just paste
in and then from there if he got a
response then he would do a real one um
but you mentioned on the website that
you'd call yourself at that time maybe a
serial dater and dumper and I found that
fascinating what is that um well I think
I think I was because I was a shy person
and I didn't really have a lot of
relationships or high school I think I
was kind of mature when I was able to
meet people you know throw a line so
it's kind of like oh man this is cool so
maybe when I was 15 if I would have gone
through that phase of you know I want to
date as many girls as I can you know and
find something serious it was more like
and you have a lot more options online
too so I think before online dating you
know you'd say well maybe a I don't like
this about the person I'm gonna work
through with them well now I don't have
to because they have so many other
people I'm talking to simultaneously
that maybe you know she's more
attractive in this last one or she has
you know better job prospects ins yeah
it's like you can just kind of mix and
match and I think that's what a lot of
the people do now because like Colleen
sits in the film it's an ego booster to
to say like hey I have all these people
want to go out with me you know who
would want that feeling that their
desired by all these people but that's
also the flip side of it is well maybe
they're talking to a bunch of
able to so when you do have a serious
connection it's like well you know
hopefully they feel the same way as you
do because we're I think we're all it
man and women are kind of in this just
kind of trap down with online dating
where you can if you don't kind of stop
and say hey this person is worth the
time worth getting to know worth you
know having a relationship with because
you could pass along a lot of good
people just because you're kind of in
this addiction to you know meet a bunch
of people so from all the people that
you talked to what was the most common
experience that they had with online
dating whether it was good or bad was it
people not looking like their photo or
or painting a rosier picture of their
financial situation what was the most
common I think the one thing I really
learned from this movie is that you know
if you have if you attract the wrong
kind of person you know off the internet
it's not going to change when you go
online you know if you attract abuse of
people you're going to meet abusive
people on the internet it doesn't matter
it's not the web sites fall that's kind
of you know what you put out there you
know that's kind of what I learned and
and also from my own experiences and I
think that's why the people were candid
with me because I did tell him about my
own experiences it wasn't like you know
it's not it's a two-way street it's like
I'm going to tell you I made the same
mistake I met the person who sent me
didn't send me a picture you know turn
out to go horrible or you know we and
that is I think the cut most common
thing too is that there is a lot of
deception because you know you want to
represent yourself you know well but I
always kind of figured if you're gonna
lie before you even meet somebody you're
going to set yourself up because they're
going to be disappointed you know if you
say you're you know hot and you're tall
and when you meet them in their short
they're heavy the prison is going to
fill be like you lied to them so you
don't I mean I personally wouldn't want
to do that to somebody but some people
do and I think you just said sits the
relationship off on a wrong foot or you
know the friendship or whatever so I
think it's interesting that you you
touch on that in terms of like we tend
to gravitate toward people that whether
they're good for us or not but that we
have a type and that that just still
translates online and I know Audrey
talked about that
and then you had another lady to that
said she noticed the same people were
online for years as she was and it was
actually kind of an eye-opener what do
you think it is that people see in that
online profile that then translates into
sort of that same dance that they're
doing with people you know whether it's
it's an abusive partner what do you
think it is that we see those signals
and then we go oh that's that's my type
whether it's good for me or not even if
it's online I think I think a lot of
people just aren't aware of for the type
you know it's their kind of more kind of
get victim mentality of like I always
you know bad guys always date me or you
know rarer you know I always get crazy
girls well instead of saying well why
why why is that happening because you
know you're complicit in it too it's not
a you know let's say kidnapped you and
they force you in a relationship but I
think that's the thing is so you don't
want to study ourselves sometimes in
figure out well why am I hat I'm in a
hat unhappy and why can't I find that
right person and a lotta I think it's
out of our control because maybe we had
a bad example as our parents and you
know that can be part of it because I
think that's informs your relationship
choices but I think what the profiles to
people aren't always honest in their
profiles because it's basically it's
like a billboard for you you know look
at me look how look how great I am so
you're not going to say you know I I can
be abusive I could be mean you know
you're going to say oh I'm very
understanding and you know I don't like
to argue you know you know you're gonna
play up your attributes rather than you
know play and lay them down it was funny
I worked on a project and there was a
guy I forget his name and he gets paid a
lot of money to write people's profiles
and he I don't know if it was a joke but
he said he had a guy was in neo-nazi he
was helping him write his profile and he
changed it to say he liked a world war
two artifacts or something like that you
played it up rather than highlight is
you know his neo-nazi aspects so I mean
you know that's kind of part of it is
you know the profile you may not get all
the information that you want and you're
probably going to get it you know when
you meet somebody but I mean I don't
even kind of tell if someone's you know
may be rude or short with you you can
kind of tell what they're going to be
like once you meet him but I think
times the problem is you have that
emotional connection online so they'd
like Audrey how she kind of forgave a
lot of things the guy did because you
thought oh I'm in love with this person
and which is kind of another interesting
thing that you can you can have an
emotional connection with somebody
before even meeting them you know just
through video chain or channel money so
there's another thing I thought was
really interesting yeah I did too
especially because you know I'd you're
talking about she's very intuitive and
empathic and and it is interesting how
someone that I mean she can tell things
about people even by looking at their
photo that that emotional component and
it's almost like falling in love with a
celebrity you have this idealized
version of who they are and and yeah her
story is is really fascinating on how
that she let that sort of happen and I
think it could happen to a lot of people
you know that you you get very seduced
by the idea of someone and and even
though it's not realistic of who they
are yeah yeah I think she I think she's
just um I don't know I mean she's a
little little kooky and some of the some
of us I mean I think she's trying to I I
don't know me it seems like she's always
gonna attract the same kind of person
unless she kind of figures out you know
maybe I should just go for the opposite
guy you know I don't know with her I
mean I hope she does find the right
person but well I think to a lot of
times people find somebody boring and
that means that's probably they're good
for them you know it's when that person
sort of is wow this is so exciting and
and that's probably your buttons being
pushed and and you're going to do that
dance together so i think someone in
there mentioned that that usually the
ones that are safe and like nice people
they didn't find interesting which is
probably a cue that they should maybe
that's the one they should go for ya
there you have it you know Pablo let's
talk a little bit about getting this the
sort of movie off the ground because you
know committing to the idea of
committing to a feature film I mean
that's a massive decision you know and
often times we don't we don't even
realize how big a decision is as we're
doing it we don't we don't realize until
years later
they're all the work that we put in and
be like wow that was really a big
decision to say it I'm gonna make this
film so so what was the idea that the
sort of you rallied around and sort of
led to the to you committing to this
film and going forward with it I think I
just I always felt that there was a
movie here and I was kind of really
surprised that there wasn't really
something similar to it already and
because of my own experiences and I just
said you know a lot of people were they
don't they may kind of know about this
but there's a lot here that hasn't been
uncovered and at first I wasn't sure if
I had a feature because basically what I
did is I shut all the interviews first
and then maybe edited all the interviews
and then we shall the b-roll stuff but
you know just became a point and I'm
sure you know you're worthless to it's
like you get so far into and you're like
I have to finish this I'm not gonna not
gonna let this go you know I just even
if nobody sees this it'll just be an
accomplishment just to finish it you
know and then maybe my friends will like
it or something but it just became about
you know we're in the middle of it I've
invested so much money and I was proud
of it i thought this is kind of one of
the best things i've done so far i said
i'd like to see this through and just
you know have a project you just to say
hey i completed this and I did it on my
own because I hadn't I'd never tried to
do a feature before so I've said you
know what let's just let's do this and
it took a long time and I was working
with a lot of people were freelancing so
you know I was kind of based on their
schedules and their dirt on tables so
you know kind of made it longer than it
should have been but you know you can
have done and I try and I try to you
know do it with the least amount of you
know money that I could do and just play
that smart but you know so it's a
big-time investment like you were saying
yeah well I think to you said that you
treat filmmaking as a hobby because you
work for a family business is that right
so you were balancing I don't know if
you work what 40 hours a week or
whatever it is but then your normal job
on top of making the film how are you
integrating your life at this time well
what was nicely about that because I
have that situation as I could say hey
you know I'd like to go work with my
editor today and I have that flexibility
but I mean it was nice about the
you know we have smartphones now in
computers as I can constantly check my
email and you know handle there's a
customer situation or you know let the
office know about something so you know
I was always kind of close to it but it
but I would maybe every week or so I'd
go meet the editor and kind of work with
him and help you know kind of get the
move the project long and so I mean I
think working in the business I work in
its kind of giving me the ability to
kind of multitask and say hey well I can
work and I can also call the animator
and make sure he's on schedule and you
know but it is hard because you know
when you're doing all this stuff by
yourself you know after a while you do
get kind of like yeah and can't help you
know I can't think of everything but I
guess it's the the passion you know for
filmmaking that we don't have that we
wanted to get the project done and it
was hard as not everyone shares that
passion that works on it you know it's
really you know you and hopefully you
know your part if you have a partner but
I mean the other people some of them do
some don't but in that's hard to get
them to have an interest can you take us
through the timeline I mean from what
from when the idea first hit you where
you said you know I'm going to make this
film all the way through when you find
it just not necessarily showcased it but
by the time you guys have done how long
long of a time period was that I think
it was about a year I kind of had the
idea while back but it was about a year
from putting up the craigslist ads and
then and it took a while to kind of
arrange the interviews because some
people would fall through and some
people just I mean it's craigslist so
you're going to do a lot of weirdos and
then you know setting up the interviews
and then editing editing took the
longest time because it was finding the
structure and then figuring out while
adding b-roll to it and figuring out you
know what kind of extra shots we need it
because I mean sometimes some people
when they do documentary they have it
all kind of scripted but I think a lot
of times it's going to be you're gonna
have all these spontaneous elements
because you don't know what you're going
to get from some of the people that you
interview so I mean in it I've been told
it's actually pretty quick for
documentary but I mean it felt it felt
long to me you know having to kind of it
just felt like it would never end at
some points but you know you just want
to keep going and you want to persevere
through it and get it out there how many
hours of footage did you have to sit
through we shud 20 which isn't which is
kind of low for a documentary I've heard
people she like 100 for a feature a lot
of times it that said but wheeling at
one camera we didn't have multiple
cameras so that could be a factor too so
I mean the mainly the interviews we
choose like an hour take an hour to
maybe an hour and a half with the people
but then I brought like Colleen I
brought her back a couple times and Andy
he told me about that Toastmasters
speech she was going to give about
online dating so when videotape that
some of the people kind of kept in
contact with me so I'd say like oh I'd
really like to have Colleen cook
something so I called her back and you
know she cooked the desert kind of give
people an idea that she really is a chef
and so so we do some kind of up in we
talk to the people that give me updates
like Andy was dating a girl or Colleen
was dating a guy and then we kind of you
know they're marty was dating that girl
so so he went back after the initial
interviews and shot that stuff in our
life Pablo you know you know just this
past week Karen pitched me an idea for a
story that she has that she wants to
develop and something I just told her
before before we kind of connected with
you here today as I said you know what I
think one thing you should do is you
should actually write down the
inspiration behind the idea like I not
just write the idea down and do that
whole thing but I feel like you know
what just write down the inspiration of
why you're doing this because you know
later on when it comes to promoting and
marketing the film but it's so helpful
to really go back to that original
inspiration you know I mean we're
getting very close to releasing our film
and it's like you know that original
inspiration was like three years ago you
know and well I'm having a light reflect
back now on what the film or what the
core idea was and it's challenging it's
like you know what you know life has
been such a blur for last three years
have you ever heard of someone not just
beginning their idea and writing that
down but also writing the inspiration
and why they're doing it no but I think
that's a really great idea because you
could go back and go guy you know
because it probably may change too
your inspiration as you go I mean it's
investing three years of your life
totally you know you may be like oh my
god why am I doing this and but yeah I
mean I would definitely do that and
remember my mom always told me about
that like you know having like life
plans and writing it down and then you
look at it later and he'd be like you
know I worded like how did I get from
here to there i would i would definitely
do that on my next project is figure out
in Hawaii who I wanted to spend it for
me I think about things so much and I
think sometimes I probably think too
much but it's kind of is in my head but
yet temperature write it down to where
you've kind of owned it you know and
baby dated it and said this is what this
is why I'm doing this it's a great thing
to do yeah I just want to put that out
there and and and something yeah
absolutely you know and with your story
that you know one of the core ideas I
guess before you know you posted the ad
on Craigslist was the initial idea that
didn't that didn't go through was you
were like you don't I'm gonna get some
of my friends together we're gonna get
them drinking we're gonna turn the
camera on them and just start having him
tell like some of their best date like
online dating stories you know I I just
thought I thought that I could just be
thinking that that's hilarious tell us
what happened there me did did you
actually attempt it or they just
wouldn't they wouldn't buy into it or
what happened well what happened I was
why I was finishing my student film it's
called sick and in the guy who did the
audio for me we spent so much time
because we're because it was a non sync
sound film than you had sound effects
and music well I wanted to complete the
project because it film school why
people don't completely finish their
films so I was working with this guy for
a long time and you know I got to know
when we would talk a lot and he was
telling me about all these women he was
mean online because I was meeting women
tuned we kind of share stories and he
was any memory of showing pictures of a
girl and every picture she was wearing a
costume like a Mickey Mouse costume not
like a sexual cause I'm just like you
know like weird and I goes are these all
from Halloween egos know she always
wears costumes okay what's a little nuts
didn't even tell me how how crazy and
all these stories and I was like how'd I
get it I want to interview this guy but
you know I think it's one thing for
people to to tell you in confidence
another thing for them to tell you
sometimes on camera because you know
that think they're afraid what's gonna
happen and then I had some other friends
who you know I would talk to him about
my internet dating and they would tell
me he and I said you know and one guy he
met a girl and she she came to school
and he was taking a final and she was
way in his room and then she she just I
thought I guess she felt he took too
long so she like threw his computer outs
I mean just like crazy and I'm like
you know that would be great to have
these you know to videotape you stories
and just do something kind of really
inexpensive that would be kind of cool
and kind of creative and but you know
it's just the reality came to reality
and then wanting to be interviewed was
like I don't know if I want to do that
now film is gonna lie I mean your movies
going to last longer than you you know
it's going to be out there so maybe they
were worried about oh you know other
women saying it or I mean who knows I
think and there are even people for
clicking for love one of the one of my
friends he was trying to get a friend if
it was a serial internet theater to be
interviewed and he didn't want to be
interviewed and I think some guys didn't
want their tricks to be kind of exposed
you know out there because they also be
a lot of people have no lines that they
use and I guess they're working so no
why publicize it women too yeah yeah we
have our little secrets that are just a
months when we go to the bathroom we
talk about it together exactly let's
talk about this let's talk did what do
you remember of the craigslist ad like
the pitch you know I'm just curious like
what your pitch letter was move did you
remember was your rope to get all these
responses yeah it was basically you know
I'm making a documentary about online
dating and I'd love to take interview
for an hour and if you have a unique
story or a funny story please contact me
and I said I would pay people twenty
dollars to do an interview because at
first I put up the as nobody responded i
thought well twenty bucks isn't bad for
an hour you know and then the next day i
think it said i would feed them too and
then they slowly would start to trickle
in and then you kind of lose the the
communications because you know the ads
move so then I would have to post
another one and the one from Andy was
really kind of funny because he said he
some friends saw the ad told him he
should
right me and he said I know that film's
name need interesting storylines so he
wrote like bullet points like you know
father offers me a hundred thousand
dollars per baby and you call it the
like he had titles for all
of his story so it's kind of funny on
going back you know like it like these
are all cinematic little stories that he
had and then Judy the lady with the dog
she's you know rode her story and it was
really long and and she was writing all
these stories about his guys and I I
called her I said well you have all
these sad stories and said why are you
still doing this again then she told me
about how her husband er er I'm sorry
her fiance died at heart attack and it
was a love of her life and they been
like on AOL and I was like okay I can
kind understand now how you think you
know you'll meet another guy that
caliber online dating so yeah just kind
of funny some people would be very vague
in their response and some of the story
that they would call or they write the
deep right mean it would just be he's
like generic like you know I went out
with this guy and he seemed like you
liked me and then he never called me and
I'm like that's not that interesting
that's you know difficult to a lot of
people's dating experiences you know you
think it's going one way and actually
goes another way so yeah we just you
know try to find people who are
interesting and Colleen she had a blog
where she wrote about all of a lot of
her dating experiences and so that she
had a lot of crazy stories so you know I
mean and I always tell people people go
well how did you people i said
well people who want to be interviewed
you know they're there usually are kind
of almost like an actor I mean they're
not actors but you know I mean it's like
they want to be they want to tell their
stories and a lot of people don't and I
think that's you know like a lot of your
friends maybe they'll don't have a new
boyfriend or girlfriend you'll see how'd
you guys meet and they won't tell you at
first but a lot of times it's online
dating because I think a lot of people
still aren't admitting it you know and
some people are but when you actually
sat down with him to do the interviews I
mean was it an hour's worth of time or
did every time did you go over but it
wasn't always an hour sometimes it was
longer but I mean I think I said an hour
but I mean a lot of times one thing I
learned from my dad my dads are really
good salesperson is people love to talk
about themselves so if you get somebody
talking about themselves and you had
some questions they're gonna you know
nobody's really tied me and said over
over an hour you
forty bucks or wasn't like and some
people didn't even take the money I
think they just wanted to tell me you
know get some of the stuff off their
chest about these crazy dating
experiences that they had so actually
the only person I paid more money was
Audrey and she asked for a hundred bucks
I think i gave her 50 or something
because she said she had this great
story and she wanted to be on oprah
rental and stuff and then that was the
first interview i did actually so but
everybody else was really cool and and
she was actually really cool too i think
she I think it was good for her to kind
of because she realized she still was
emotional about her breakup and kind of
get her tears out and now get all the
feelings out now like Judy too and that
she had gone through so many different
ones from the fiance dying unfortunately
to a guy that she did like who would do
these disappearing acts and then come
back in and I think that's a very common
thing and a lot of people's lives I'm
wondering from the craigslist responses
that you received what were some of the
craziest as you got um i would think
well you know it wasn't so much the
craigslist ads would be like when you'd
call a person to follow up and the guy
who was helping me to same was joshi cuz
the one who called marty and when he
called Marty more I start to tell him
about how he was in a porno movie and
how in all these pictures so some of the
craigslist ads would be kind of more you
know there wasn't this salacious but
it's like when you would call a person
then they start to kind of tell you more
but like Judy when she wrote me
basically had her whole story and it
will basically listed a bunch of bad
dates and how you know she had always
bad luck and that's why I asked her why
you still doing this you know when I was
on the phone with her and then she's
mentioned her the love of her life
Harold Audrey I think did mention about
this boat captain and you know she kind
of made it sound a little mysterious and
Colleen send all these blog entries and
they were so we were pretty graphic
about sexual encounters and stuff and
she's kind of a you know funny person so
I was kind of like guide them can you
cuz she said in these blogs like oh this
is a ton of stuff that real it's time to
read it and pick out all these stories
he can kind of tell me your top story so
then she listed some of her kind of top
stories and be i think it was mainly
what's he called the person and then
they would kind of get tell you more of
what was going on but like Andy he
listed all the stories that he said I
think he had a couple more but kind of
tried think it was the weirdest one cuz
it's a couple years back now but
actually there was one girl and she said
she had an asian fetish and that she met
her husband online and she kind of had a
crazy story but twenty bucks was enough
money for her it's okay well whatever
you know thanks so we just had never
interviewed her that's I think some
people had think they had better stories
than they actually had I see right right
well I mean as I said earlier we open
the show him you had a great
cross-section of people so what made you
choose the interviews that you went with
were they just the people were more they
were consistent they followed up is that
yeah it was the time consistent followed
up and seemed interesting you know
because I the documentaries I tend to
like or ones about kind of quirky people
you know like like crumb or trying to
thinks any other ones but or the
American movie you know where you follow
this person that's so interesting and I
wanted people who had the they wanted
him to be characters but also to have
genuine stories too rather than just you
know somebody's let go you know I went
out with somebody and they never coming
back it's like well that's that's not
interesting and that's typical hope a
lot of people were there any folks that
you interviewed and your way through the
whole process and then when you were
editing they came to you and said you
know what I don't want to be in the film
anymore no auditory didn't want me to
use some you cheat some YouTube videos I
thought might be kind of interesting to
used but that was the only thing but
nobody nobody said oh I don't want to be
in it but a lot some of the people
though they haven't really like when
I've when we get screenings they haven't
really participated I think maybe they
just aren't interested anymore but
everyone was pretty I think they were
really surprised when they saw the
finished film because they didn't know
about each other the only kind of knew
that I interviewed one person so when
they saw it all together like oh my god
this is so hold you know it's kind of a
real movie it's not just you know little
thing about me so that I think really
took them by surprise to see the whole
thing put together
so when you went to meet these people
and you paid them their twenty dollars
and bought some lunch or whatever were
you getting them to sign a release form
yes okay yeah we didn't we interviewed a
lot of people in my office and had lunch
brought in and then I had I don't know
if it's my girlfriend or somebody else I
had a couple people on crew and we had
release forms and then we just had him
sign release forms so just really
important how people sign release forms
you know in terms of when you actually
sit down to interview them I mean how
did you decide in terms of where you
were going to film them and where you
were going to place the camera you know
can you talk about that a server the
filmmaking yeah we did I think we did in
in my conference room we had a nice area
and we knew that would be a good place
so we shot some there I think we shud
over two days and then we shot in the
entry because there's like a cool tile
glass pattern so we would just say you
know why we've shot here enough we'll
just move over there and we kind of pre
lit the area's your knowing where we
would film so it's pretty easy as pretty
much you know they just came we might
dome they sat down we interviewed them
and you know they could go so it was
pretty pretty pretty quick and easy and
how much prompting did you have to do
and they come prepared in terms of like
this is my story this is what I'm
sharing how much interaction did you
have with them um I asked all the
questions so it was quite a bit
interaction I mean me what either tried
to do is rather than have them because a
lot of times when you do a documentary
you say can you restate the question in
your answer and I just stopped doing
that and just I just it was like we're
talking now I just imagine if I had the
camera on you guys and I was like that
was my interview so it was very
conversational rather than you know
let's go back and redo that it was I
tried to make it really natural and and
it made it a little hard editing
sometimes to kind of give the contacts
but um I think you know if you make
people feel comfortable and like I said
a lot of the new some of my own stories
because I talked to them so I think they
felt like they were almost commiserating
with me about stuff and like when when
somebody would talk about the pictures
being wrong I would say yeah that
happened to me too and tell them my
story so
it was more of a conversation than like
an interrogation you know kind of thing
like you know what are you doing so well
is that how you got people to be so
comfortable you kind of did that
self-disclosure first as a way to like
kind of lead the way in terms of opening
the door to honesty and because people
were very candid in those inner yeah I
think I think I mean I think it kind of
comes from my mom but like we both have
kind of personalities were people just
for some reason tell his stuff yeah and
I and I think maybe it's just my
personality or something but yeah I
think it did help i mean the the the one
person was hard was um what was the
girls name the girl played video games
in the movie i'm forgetting her name now
but she was very kind of like guarded
about everything and but everyone else
is pretty open but I because I'd been
interacting with them through emails and
just kind of you know setting up the
interviews and I think they probably did
feel comfortable it wasn't just like you
know they were talking to somebody else
and then somebody else interviewed him
you know that it was the same person i'm
sure they kind of put him a little bit
at ease interesting well Pablo you wrote
a wonderful article for film courage
calm entitled clicking for love and the
hard realities of indie filmmaking and
we want to read just a quick apart from
that article you explain your situation
for your film you say quote I spent way
too much money traveling to poorly
attended film fest that didn't help
publicize my film one iota there is
merit in winning prizes and putting a
laurel leaf graphics on box art because
this may persuade someone to purchase
the film by setting your film apart as
an award winner but this doesn't matter
if no one sees it so tell us about your
film festival experience the best one
I've been to was the first one I got
into which was tuned acula which is
actually a really well attended festival
and I think you know why I think it
still has value though is maybe not for
you guys because you guys have a
following and you guys have interacted
with a lot of filmmakers but for me to
go to the film festivals in to meet
other filmmakers and make contacts was
actually pretty valuable for me but
since you since the two you guys are
constant talking with filmmakers and
learning from other people it may not
have that value for you but I I still do
think that was an indie film without
stars in it
I think people may be persuaded by
seeing a laurel leaf and saying hey you
know made this one in a warrant so maybe
it is good but you know they may look
closer and say well it's not Sundance
it's not Slamdance don't know but you
know I go to these festivals and there
would be the only people be there would
be the other filmmakers and I don't know
if it's like a scam to to make money and
you know there's very little promotion
like you go these theaters and then
being these strip centers and opening
this trip centre would even know about
the festival and like now why are they
promoting this you know why not give me
don't you want people to come beside the
filmmaker so I mean that just got kind
of old after a while so I think my
advice would be and for me and in for
you guys with your film is if you're
going to apply to fest probably just to
apply to the top tier ones and maybe the
second level ones because those but like
newport beach festival is a huge
festival it's really well attended very
well promoted that's local if you can
get in the festival like that it's why i
think it's worth it but i mean like some
of the smaller ones like aof you're
going to find more people you put it up
on YouTube probably more people see it
then are going to go to that screen
which is kind of sad because I think you
know a lot of us love movies and you
know why not you know advertise your
festival and promote it can you take us
on that timeline as well I mean when did
you first are submitting the festivals
and then kind of where are you now I
mean how many festivals have you I mean
how many festivals you did you submit to
and then how many did you get in and
look I did around 80 you can i got in
around 13 and basically when i talk to
other people that was kind of their hit
rate to was about ten percent of what
they apply to some people less but
there's a lot of things to that our
festivals are like their contests
basically where you win an award and I
have a I have a choke my I was telling
my friend why we should create our own
contest and you know use the filmmaker
the universe award everybody submits
wins you know so you can say I one you
know filmmaker the universe and put that
on your box and because I mean that's
the equivalent of some of these things
you know it's like you win this award
and there's not even screens or anything
it's just like somebody picks
Davies out awards to films and it's like
that everybody who applied goodna Ward I
mean you don't know you know how many
people hold why it so it's kind of kind
of interesting but I mean it's been fun
though to kind of networking with people
and meeting people hopefully what can
work with on my next projects but it's
not like there's because you know like I
think what like what you guys have done
is you guys have build an audience with
your podcast and and you want you know
my impression was if I go to film
festivals I can build an audience and
meet people and hopefully they'll want
to buy my film or you know want to click
like on my facebook page or something
but it was like it was there wasn't that
audience there and I thought was kind of
sad because you know somebody who loves
films like I would have gotta go to
local festival if I knew about and it
was promoted yeah I want to see what
people might community or making or you
know people outside the community to or
coming in because people like people
would fly to Myrtle Beach or they fly
across the country to go you know this
film festival and nobody was there you
know and you spent a lot of money doing
it I mean how many festivals did you
travel to all together I mean you got
into 13 how many did you actually attend
i went to myrtle beach i attended a lot
of him i went to uh there was one in
Vegas that was similar they just like
rented out a little conference room and
they had awards and they didn't even
scream my movie and I want some award
but I kind of went I went there because
I met a filmmaker in temecula who happen
to live in vegas i thought all be cool i
could see him and go to so it's kind of
like you kind of say well like I just
went to Portland for HDFS and that was
similar thing like nobody's really there
but i want to see portlyn I've never
been there so maybe that could be your
ulterior motive as to go see some places
you haven't been doing you know and
hopefully maybe the festival is you know
well promoted in people 10 but I know it
seems like a lot of these smaller ones
or not and it almost thought it'd be
better for like filmmakers like you and
me to create our own festival because no
we know what it takes and I think we
would do a better job promoting movies
and you know something it's not
festivals it's not easy problem you care
and I when we hosted a screening series
for two years you know here in la at the
downtown
dependent and it's incredibly
challenging it's incredibly challenging
get people to come out and support ya
know these smaller films you know and
there's so much competition well we
found it was mostly the cast and crew
that would come out nah not people
outside of the elite and we would
advertise it so many places it was is
very difficult to have people and
obviously the film it screen a year
prior that was just no chance you know
what I think kind of sucks too is I keep
these festivals and like people who are
local they'd have all their cast and
crew come so they would have a pretty
big attendance but then they leave after
their movie yeah you know they wouldn't
sit there and I mean to be courteous I
would do that i would i would watch the
shorts before my movie and watch other
thing I mean I just think it's kind of
like you know why not check something
else out but yeah I mean I know it's
hard to promote it but but you would go
to these festivals and people who
literally the restaurant was right next
to the theater had no idea that the
screening was going on you know they
didn't even walk next door and put up a
flyer you know and that to me it's like
how if they don't even know about it
you're in trouble you know or you go on
their twitter feed and there's nobody
talking about the festival you know that
you know that's a problem that's a red
flag right there yeah I mean it takes so
much effort it takes so much to so much
effort so much work so much energy to
actually get people out and out and out
of the theater you know I mean we've
been very fortunate so far because of
all the work we've done with film
prayers and everything that were very
close to selling out our world premiere
of goodbye promise but at the same time
we never sold out a screening you know
dirt during our interactive series you
know we came very close twice but we
never actually sold out it's incredibly
hard again and there were some
incredible films I mean just absolutely
brilliant ones and and sometimes the
turnout would be like 15 people and so
it really depended on that filmmakers
network and how much hustle was put into
it from your speaking with other
filmmakers is do they have the same
sentiment about film festivals that you
do or do you think that you are sort of
in a contrarian group no they feel the
same way and I know a lot of them are
there is saying you know what next time
I'm not going to spend the money to put
festival so I'm going to like they're
trying to do what you guys are doing
trying to build an audience and kind of
promote to the audience and I mean and I
think I think it's a great idea but it's
really hard to stand out you know with
all these different things and I think
they kind of see to that the festival
thing is just kind of changing but but i
truly do think it does have value if you
get into a big one if you get in the
side because it's thick you're going to
have a lot of people everywhere there to
see the films and they're really well
promoted like I went to a Newport
festival last year and I mean it was
nine day compared to the festival's that
vintage it's the amount of people in
line the excitement you know and it like
you said it also is the filmmaker
getting people to go but it really helps
when you have an audience there who's
there to support the festival too so but
yeah I think a lot of them are kind of
feeling the same way a lot of them were
kind of like me this is the first time
they really tried to get into a lot of
festivals so you know it's and I
thinking things are just changing so we
have to kind of figure out what what's
the best way to interest people in our
movies and it to me it's like you I
always hear people talk about well put
on YouTube oh that doesn't mean people
are going to see it you know like a lot
of the things that get millions of views
it's not organic you know it sound like
they just put it up there they give
known as a food is it's like there's
money behind it you know that there's
time you spend putting it on blogs and
directing people there and people what
amazes me is that people come up to you
and say I liked your podcast episode but
they won't like your Facebook page and
it's like well how hard is it just a
click like on a Facebook page or you
know it's like taking that little
internet dating a little not a time you
know that's what strange to me is how
maybe there's just too many things for
people to focus on I don't know I'm
trying to figure it out put um well too
with the YouTube a lot of those when you
look at someone's channel and has
millions of views if you look at when
they joined it was one YouTube first
started so it's a lot harder now to get
views and and you're competing with so
much um so with your podcast it's the
podcast right you talk podcast like my
name is positive okay and how many
episodes have you done I think I've done
13 13 and yeah they're about 30 minutes
long and what i did a lot of people I've
now in the festival circuit I interview
when we talk about their experiences and
I just interviewed a friend of mine who
I went to film school with who's a set
dresser he's been in the industry for
around like 12 years and he's trying to
break in the East done some spec
commercials he's trying to trying to
break into that and kind of move away
from set dressing so thought that was
kind of interesting to see you know
because you could people that you go to
film school you're gonna have a job in
the film industry and it's you know it's
not really true you don't there's not
like a well here's the directing job
right here it's you know you basically
have to do it your own like getting
people the screening you know it's it's
all about you and you know who you know
what I mean so what are you trying to do
with your film now you have it online
it's available for purchase so there's
like a pal link well you can buy it you
can buy a copy of it on DVD I've had
some interest recently from a
distributor and I'm kind of weigh my
options because I've put in a lot of
money in the movie and I had a legal
dispute with the movie so I'm trying to
figure out you know is it something do I
want to put in more money into it
because it's kind of the end of its run
you said the last festival screening and
you know I think I'd rather work on
something new to be honest and kind of
go back and now get this thing ready for
to be distributed and I've heard a lot
of horror stories from people who
feather films distributed and they
haven't made any money on them you know
and they've had to put in a bunch of
money for the deliverables in so I'm
kind of weighing those options right now
I mean I'd almost rather just like that
guy that you interview put it up on
vimeo and you know have habit for free
for people to watch and you know maybe
somebody will say wow I like what he did
with you know that film and I'll maybe
invest in his next movie or you know or
i'll buy a copy of it because i didn't
want support it or because it mean that
would be the most gratifying these just
want people to see your movies what you
want you know you want people to enjoy
it and see it so and have you reached
out to any of the dating size or because
maybe some of the people's experiences
were negative they haven't endorsed it
over initially I was talking to a guy I
know who he did some work with the
harmony but yeah I haven't reached out
in the dating websites I tried to reach
out to there's like blogs like
dan blogs and stuff like that and but
like you guys know I mean it's a lot of
work and you almost I almost wish I
would have put money aside for somebody
to marketing and promotion and you know
because it's like they know kind of the
middleman they know the people to go to
with the blogs and you know because if
you do it on your own you're learning at
all as you go and you're spending a lot
of time and yeah just I guess I guess
the good thing is that I'm learning a
lot of things now with this film that
you know hopefully do differently in the
future because it just it just seems
like you know you really do need to take
those steps like because if you want it
to be on iTunes you have to find an
aggregator and you've got to pay that
money and itunes isn't going to deal
with you directly so you know probably
put a site to grant and your budget for
that if you want it to be how many tunes
or you know on another digital platform
so just learning those things it's kind
of been invaluable for me with this what
about a nap um yeah that would be a good
idea i haven't actually thought about
that yeah i wanted to do like a dating
like there's a game on the webpage i
know if you saw it but it kind of tell
you who your most like that's trying to
think of something like that as a nap
but again I think it's love to promote
it though you know you stuff to figure
out a way to get it out there and I mean
I think it would be a great idea but I
think right now to I'm just kind of
burnt out on the movie you know like
it's I think it's run its course and you
know I've kind of learned everything I
could from it I'm like you know I just
want to do something else now and that's
smart because some people i think don't
know when to kind of let up project and
i don't want to say die because it's
still the page will still live on it but
to walk away ok you know it's time for
something new and so in keeping it that
what what is your next project it or do
not have one yet are you still know i
should i have one i started writing it
it's actually about that a friend of
mine and I in high school and we kind of
two guys who kind of we like to make fun
of each other and kind of bust each
other's balls a lot and and I think it's
going to be assured because I kind of
figure right now I'd rather kind of take
the tie and do something really focus on
a short you know and then figure out if
I'm going to go with festival route but
kind of do something where wouldn't be
huge investment of money but it's also a
story I'm really passionate about
tell and then you know see where it
could see where it goes to that because
I haven't worked with actors in a while
you know been doing this documentary to
kind of get my feet wet with that again
and then maybe maybe do a feature but
like I gave it was saying you know
feature is a huge investment of time and
you know I hit rather just kind of get
comfortable kind of the short because
it's been a while I haven't really made
anything for two years so and for me
it's like your name your show film
courage it's like I have to kind of
build up the courage again to do it you
know it's like I love movies but
sometimes it's just so much easier not
to to worry about you know although
filmmaking itself and the Duke you know
fun stuff in your life but I mean it is
fun but it's you know it's the Battle of
filmmaking yeah and it's the battle we
get your film scene and we're sort of
right on the brink of that right now you
know we hope we have some sort of
solution as we get to get ready to
release goodbye promise what were you
know at this point in time we're just
not able to talk about it until we
actually do it yeah um but one thing I
do want to talk about is I want to talk
about where you were before you went to
the film festival circuit you know
because that that seems to be the thing
that we keep coming across is is
independent filmmakers finish their film
they do not necessarily intact big big
name actors in it and so you'd have to
find a way and we all kind of go to the
film festival circuit you know and
obviously we hope like you know a
festival like Sundance will pick it up
but you know really that that's not
that's not the reality for most of us
where were you at when you started
saying okay we're going to start you
know what was it what would what were
your hopes and expectations at that
point in time before the film festival
started well whether you know in the
past way submitted to film festivals I'd
only do one or two and then I get
discouraged because I get rejection
letters I see you want you can't do it
this way you got a really kind of swing
for the fences and you know just go for
it so that's what i did i said i'm going
to apply it as many as i can and i
always hope that you know that it would
get distributed and people would see it
and that was my greatest hope was to be
that people would you know get a chance
to see it because it seems like when
people see it they like it but it's just
getting them to see
and it's the issue for a lot of films so
I mean my I think my ultimate goal was
for it to be in soon she really top-tier
film festivals and maybe somebody like
in saying hey you know give you money
for your next movie or near you know
just working meeting other people I can
work with but I think my hope was to is
finding people who would support the
movie and just would like in that was
kind of my ankle was just to make
something that people would enjoy and
and you know hopefully it hopefully make
some money back on it but I mean I think
right now like a filmmaker I interviewed
John has he said you know right now
you're not going to make money with a
movie he goes any time out if he's gonna
do a project to do a web series just as
you can get exposure and get your name
out there and stuff but I mean I i think
you know it's I think it's the
courageous aspect of it is you know it's
not really going to be about the money
right now it's about establishing you
hopefully your fan base and building a
library of films that people love and
want to see so that's kind of what my
planners well one other thought I want
to come back to is you know we do also
here kind of the same kind of testimony
or they came to same kind of thought in
terms of filmmakers wanted to go to film
festivals and connecting with other
filmmakers and hopefully connecting with
an audience people that come on to the
film and you've done that you've
attended you know most of the vessels
you gotten into have you been able to
parlay those connections into into you
know people supporting your film online
you know you know either buying the DVD
or clicking on facebook or sharing the
movie at me have you been able to do
that I think little by little I mean not
so much people buying the movie but more
people go into facebook page and and
I've made like the filmmaker contacts
I've made like for me it's I'd rather my
girlfriend would make fun of me because
I'd always give screeners out of people
she be like why don't you charge and I'm
like well I don't know but you know you
give them a screener they'll give you a
screener and I think it's more kind of
about we're all on the same battle
together and I've met some really good
people who I hope want to you know work
with me on my next movie because and
like when i watch the videos on your
guys pocket I mean you learn so much
there's so many things we all have to
share and I think at a film festival
some filmmakers are very kind of in
their own corner and you know
I don't want to deal with anybody else
but it's like really I think if we kind
of come together and we kind of say hey
look I've done it because there's I
don't think there's really an A to B way
to do everything we're all doing things
differently like the way you're doing
your your premier your film the way
you're going to distribute it is it's
different and it's not wrong it's not
right but maybe I can learn from it you
know or like the guy put the movie up on
vimeo and got 30,000 views it's it's
like there's so many different ways of
do things and I think if we kind of help
each other out and supplicate each
other's adversaries look at each other's
maybe we can learn stuff from each other
I think I think that's really been what
I've taken away from the film festival
experience and I have heaven people I've
met who really did like the movie and
but i think the the economy is the way
has changed to is before you know you
buy a DVD for a movie you give it a shot
because you know we didn't have all
these dvds in our closet now we have too
many dvds so i think people are a little
resistant now to buying something that
they don't know because there's not a
star in it you know there's not and most
people are streaming things now on
netflix or you know instead of buying a
physical DVD so i think that's changed
whereas maybe if i made the movie 10
years ago would have been oh sure i'll
buy your DVD yeah sure and the same for
people seeing it in the theater too
because now it's like okay well how much
is this going to cost in gas and is
there parking and whatever yeah so it's
there's so much more cost that goes
involved in sort of seeing the film then
used to be I think to leak if you if you
guys didn't do a screening the only
other advantage would be the CEO movie
on the big screen yeah you know at a
film festival but you know the
projectionists are not top-notch
especially these kind of beads sea level
film festivals like you always hear
people talking about shooting on
whatever the primo cameras and I don't
think it really even matters that these
vessels because you get projectionists
or making so many mistakes and you know
that sometimes or they're they're
screening the DVD instead of your
blu-ray Aaron you know all these things
can happen so in the end it's like you
know you you're pretty movie it's not
going to look as great you know up on
that screen it's because they don't have
the care that you know you put into it
but I think I mean that is I think can
be an advantage if you want to see your
film on the big screen you know probably
for an indie film is probably a good way
to go over to some film festivals and
let's like do what you're doing in rent
a theater which i think is at all you
know the good way to I mean looking back
on it you know because it almost sounds
like you're saying you know you started
with with temecula which is an
outstanding film festival and then from
there it really kind of plateaued to a
lower level I mean do you almost wish
that you had that maybe you had gotten
an aggregator on early boards like but
you kind of rolled the wave of Temecula
and then immediately you know you know
when sort of an aggregated Robin and got
it into itunes another platform so that
with that would that have been a better
way to go about it yeah I think so i
think you're fighting a publicist who
can help you because the publicist know
all the media people for these young
local media in these festivals and they
know how to write you a good press
release and that kind of mean it's just
stuff you know because it's a filmmaker
what's your main goal is to make your
move you're not thinking about festivals
nothing about entry cost you nothing
about screen or you know all this stuff
happens later but I think you know the
earlier you think about this stuff the
better off you'll be and I think you
know finding an aggregator I mean
there's lots of people out there who do
that and just considering you know
putting aside that money because there's
these middlemen who kind of control of
the I guess they're the gatekeepers and
you kind of can't get around them you
know if you want to be on iTunes which
is the biggest way you know people are
going to download your movie now so or
Amazon there I mean you can do I forget
the thing for Amazon you remember it
create space you can submit your movie
through create space but they don't
promote it but and I think they take
thirty percent of what you would you
read what you recoup but I mean it's
another way you can do it through amazon
put up your pride your film or your book
or whatever that's great i mean it's
almost a no-brainer to go on amazon
and I mean you know it's still a great
discovery tool and and and it doesn't
really cost anything it's like you can
just get it up there no matter what the
film is there's no there's no one to
stop you from doing it so ya know it's a
no brainer together it's it's a trick of
getting them to it that's still the
thing where you know you have to spend
money promoting some our you know go
into blogs you think will direct people
to you know your type of movie and
that's I think we're all trying to
figure out is how do we how do we get
people to our movies you know Wow
especially now too because there's so
much information so many updates from
facebook so many things in the Twitter
feed that even if it looks so
interesting like me having tweetdeck on
I can't click on all that stuff I get ya
done so it's we're competing for so much
more just the same as on YouTube you
know where is in 2006 there was less on
there competing and everybody's making
movies note 2 and I was think about this
too late when I was in high school we
did have a film production class that
seems like a lot of kids now are
learning film production in high school
so they know what I headed they know how
to shoot see you have more and more
people making stuff and there's less and
more plus people who are taking the
chance on the indie projects you know
probably within less money in their
pocket to buy DVDs and go to the movies
and all that stuff I mean it sounds
discouraging but I think if you have a
good film I think you could still stand
out it's just taking the time and
pushing it and you know doing what you
guys are doing you know running up the
inner and show it to people and you know
because if you make in a vacuum no one's
going to know about it yeah it also
sounds like the lesson here also is I
mean as you move on to your next
projects you already have this stuff in
mind you're thinking about it you know
in fact that we're talking about it here
it puts other filmmakers in a position
for them to be thinking about it as they
make their projects you know so you know
hopefully there then hearing this it's
like we're putting them a little bit
further ahead of the game yeah when I
went back to my film school after I
think after Temecula and the kids in the
class had no idea about without a box
and you know all these basic things I'm
like I think I should be on without a
box because they were going to make
their thesis film like if you're going
to submit the film festivals you're
getting to have your screeners you can
have to be on without a box you know you
can actually have a travel budget you
all these kind of things and it's like
you know you know all you're thinking
about is making your film you're not
thinking about how do i promote it next
how do I get out there and so I mean
it's just in the that's just I guess
just learning it you know the but
hopefully people learn it from listening
to us and rather than having you know
making the mistakes they can save
themselves some time there you have it
there you have it we've been speaking
with Pablo pappano of the film clicking
for love um you know which which is
about the world of online dating for
more on Pablo and clicking for love
please visit clicking for love.com
there's a shirt no I was watching you
know they get the t-shirt you can
connect with him on Twitter at cancer
man 28 and it's been an absolute
pleasure at you know just just taking
time out and been trying to been able to
connect with you this way Pablo yeah
thank you so much and you can also go to
facebook.com slash a podcast or podcast
I'm sorry show for his podcast which is
the world according to Pablo with
filmmaking politics team or you can also
go to IMDB and then you can also read
Pablo's article on film courage calm
entitled clicking for love and the hard
realities of indie filmmaking and also
you can check out the clicking for love
website and they have a dating tests
which problem mentioned earlier and a
review from Phil threat so yeah you
haven't got a really good review from
film thread which is really cool because
I'm a big fan that I was a fan of the
magazine and the website now huh oh yeah
like Mark Bell well thank you again
Pablo for joining us and really loved
the film it's funny I'm great thank you
in an online dater but just watching it
uh it's just it's it's funny it's also
there's some sad parts too but i highly
recommend all of you to check it out and
if you know someone who isn't online
dater um make a good Christmas gift so
great thanks London good luck with your
premiere yeah thank you thank you pablo
all right take care